(upbeat music)
- All right everybody, we're
back with the one and only,
my dear friend, Deborah Norville.
Now this story I loved
because I struggle with timing myself.
I like to have these really
in-depth conversations
with people and I heard a tip
that when you are ready to wrap it up
that you have something you do.
What is it?
- Okay, so when I was on the Today Show,
because it's very, very finely timed.
- And that is live, and that
is a whole different thing.
- They will cut you off, the
computer will cut you off.
So I said to this person
I was interviewing, I said
because they were not a professional.
There was somebody who was just an amateur
who doesn't go on TV a lot.
I said, when it's time for us to wrap up,
I'll just briefly, I'll
just tap you with my foot
and that means comfortably
finish what you're saying.
So I get the sign from the
person behind the camera.
I go like that, nothing happens.
I hit a little bit harder.
I'm not gonna hit you as hard
as, so I hit this person.
I'm basically beating
the pie out of this guy.
Finally, I have to cut him off.
He had a prosthesis.
(group laughing)
I mean, for the love of Mary,
would you not tell them,
well tap the other leg?
'Cause I'm like, I was so embarrassed.
And then I felt like,
God, I'm hurting him.
I'm like, it doesn't have a leg.
It was the most embarrassing
thing that nobody
knew I was embarrassed.
So I shouldn't even be
telling this story, but I do.
- How was your like goodbye to him?
Like, did you mention it?
- Thank you so much.
No, God no.
No, no, no, no.
I'm like, I mean, if he's
not gonna bring it up,
I'm not gonna bring it up.
I mean, he did say okay,
yeah, I should have mentioned
or something like that.
I'm like, I'm not gonna
say yeah, you should have.
I'm like, you guys been through enough?
- Oh my God, that is just-
- Then there was another
time I was interviewing
we were interviewing the wives
of the guys who were running
for president.
I won't tell you it was,
and the interview's over
and we stand up and the commercial
break and something fell
out of her skirt.
And you know how when
somebody drops something
you make a move to like
go down and get it?
I'm halfway down.
It's her retainer.
- Like teeth like retainer?
- Well just the wire part.
Yeah, just the wire part.
- Gotta straighten those teeth.
- She was so sweet though.
She was like, oh, I'm so sorry.
And she was even quicker than me.
Thank the Lord.
And she picked that thing up.
- Oh my God, I love it.
And not just life.
When you're a constantly at
work, these things happen.
Okay, now speaking of
things happen at work
you have done all this undercover stuff
or all this reporting as
we start at the beginning,
of all the different
lives, jobs, shoes, roles
you've stepped into.
- So much fun.
- Bring us in, one of
them was a jail cell.
- That was not my choice.
They made me go there.
They made me go twice.
So what is it they say, fool me twice?
Shame on me.
So yeah, but that this is
what misery looks like.
I am going around to
these ladies and saying,
I'm here because my
producers don't like me.
What are you in for?
'Cause I wanted to like know.
Okay, you're just stole money
from from the McDonald's.
I'm not too scared of you.
You set your boyfriend on
fire and his leg burned off.
So I mean seriously, that was
a lady in the cell next to me.
- That's what I was interested in.
When your roommate is someone
like burnt their boyfriend,
like, allegedly set him on fire.
Do you tiptoe around that person?
- Oh, big time.
- Real delicately?
- Oh, big time, yeah.
- Not wanting to upset them.
- Yeah. We're like, here have my dessert.
- Yeah, exactly.
Oh my God, I love that story so much.
- And here's the crazy thing.
So she allegedly set
her boyfriend on fire.
The poor woman could not make bail.
She was in jail
for a year and a half waiting trial,
finally came time to have the trial.
Her boyfriend missed and loved her.
He refused to testify.
The woman got out and they
lived back together again.
Love is a beautiful thing.
- That's the weirdest,
happiest ending ever.
I love that.
- This is what we do at Inside Edition.
We tell weird happy endings.
- It's my favorite
because it's just so dynamically
diverse and its content.
And that's something I want to do here.
I love comedy.
Why do we have to wait
till late night to laugh?
Screw that, I want to
laugh in the daytime.
(audience applauding)
I want to cover news.
I want to cover human interest.
It would be wonderful to
speak to people of note.
I want to meet people
I've never met before.
I like to get into fashion stuff.
We're gonna do that on this show.
I want to have takeaways.
I want to learn how to live better.
I want it to be all these things.
Inside Edition is that.
And by the way, the pioneer in digital
the YouTube numbers are
one everyone admires,
every business on the planet
looks at Inside Edition.
That's how you do it.
I'm talking hundreds of millions of hits.
- We have, I think it's
19 billion lifetime views.
It's insane.
They're, it's so crazy.
So you guys know we're a TV show.
You're here at the taping of the TV show.
There are young people
like 10, 12, 14 years old.
- That's how they consume.
- Inside Edition's a digital show.
And they'll go to their, did
you know there's this really
great show I see on the
computer, it's actually on TV.
They think it's a new show on TV.
It's crazy.
We'll take it.
- Well speaking of a younger
generation, as a last story
I wanted to ask you about your daughter.
Because I as the mother of two daughter,
and by the way, this is
also in honor of Deborah.
It's my latest gratitude journal.
She's the one who, when we
were launching this show,
and I write in it, all the time.
And my daughter's write in it.
- You guys all write in the same book?
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
That was their latest entry.
It's a hot mess.
- Okay, wait a minute.
I am grateful for mom.
And then you guys went on a trip.
- Oh my God, I didn't.
And then Frankie says
she's grateful for sushi,
but it's spelled S-O-O-S-H-Y.
Sushi.
- She might go to that
school my daughter went to,
they were all about phonetic spelling.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But good luck with that.
- And then I get friends to write in it,
someday I'll bring it to dinner
and just be like everybody write it it.
- Oh, I love that.
- So you've changed my life with this.
And I'm raising my
daughter now to be aware
of the Gratitude journal.
- It's everywhere.
- Your daughter made your
producers or you aware
of a musician and what was she like?
Mom we got you got interview this.
- She did, she said, mom,
there's this new guy and he's really good,
entertainer, singer
and you need to put him on Inside Edition.
So I went to my producer and I said
my daughter says there's
this amazing person we need
to put on Inside Edition.
And he ignored me and Justin
Bieber turned out to be famous.
(group gasping)
Okay.
- So then cut to, she suggests another-
- Another group that she's
already gotten her dad
to bring the CD from
London so she can have it.
Mom, they're coming to America
for the very first time
and attention must be paid.
So I go to my boss and
I say do not make me say
I told you so twice.
And he said, okay fine.
We'll do the story on one condition
that Micella does the interview.
My daughter did the
first American interview
with One Direction.
(audience applauding)
And look at the kisses.
She got kisses from
every single one of them.
(group cheering)
- I mean this is the happiest story.
Deborah Norville, I thank you.
Catch her every weekday on Inside Edition.
And next if you're worried
your plants are not gonna
make it through the winter,
we have a trick, that's good.
I love my plants.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)